[Aplausos]
[Música]
a pesar de ser un pequeño país de apenas
20 millones de habitantes durante al
menos las últimas siete décadas taiwán
ha sido uno de esos puntos calientes de
la política internacional
su nombre oficial no es taiwán sino
república de china y es que su origen se
encuentra en el país que surgió en china
tras la revolución de xinhai de 1912 una
revolución que supuso la caída de la
dinastía qin
sin embargo la historia no termina aquí
pocos años después china iba a vivir una
nueva catarsis con la invasión del
imperio de japón que logró controlar la
parte más rica y poderosa del país
y cuya capitulación en 1945 sirvió como
caldo de cultivo para que estallara una
nueva guerra por el poder de los
comunistas de mao contra los
republicanos nacionalistas del
kuomintang
y ya os podéis imaginar quién ganó
verdad no logró establecer su república
popular en la china continental mientras
que los líderes contra revolucionarios y
lo que quedaba de su ejército se
establecieron en la isla de formosa
allí formaron un estado considerado
durante décadas como el legítimo sucesor
del modelo de gobierno que existía antes
de la invasión de japón y la posterior
revolución comunista
es decir para que nos entendamos el
legítimo gobierno de la república de
china
[Música]
y así durante más de 30 años el gobierno
nacionalista de taiwán fue para muchos
países el interlocutor válido el
gobierno auténtico de china el heredero
de la revolución de xinghai el gobierno
cuya legitimidad abarcaba todo el país
bajo esa perspectiva el régimen de mahou
no era más que un gobierno que ocupaba y
legítimamente buena parte del país de
hecho es ha sido tradicionalmente la
reivindicación de las autoridades
taiwanesas
rojo porque no hablamos precisamente de
una democracia sino también de una
férrea dictadura bajo el control de
chiang kai-shek para que os hagáis una
idea hasta 1996 no se celebraron
elecciones libres a pesar de ello
gracias a su alianza con eeuu hasta 1971
la república de china es decir taiwán
ocupó el asiento que le corresponde a
china en la onu en detrimento de la
república popular fundada y pilotada por
mao tse tung
sin embargo en 1971 todo empezó a
cambiar ese año taiwán perdió su asiento
en la onu a favor de la república
popular china
claro a ver un país sólo puede tener una
representación en la onu si hay dos
gobiernos que se consideran legítimos
pues hay que optar por uno o por otro
porque esta es la clave de taiwán nunca
se ha considerado como un país
independiente sino como la legítima
china unión
[Música]
el caso es que a partir de ahí a partir
de ese momento el reconocimiento
internacional y la influencia de taiwán
no han hecho más que caer en picado
ahora bien qué sucedió con aquel taiwán
que un día fue reconocido plenamente por
todas las grandes potencias occidentales
que ocurre ahora que la china
continental se ha convertido en toda una
superpotencia que ha ocurrido con la
reivindicación de taiwán y lo que es
todavía más importante que podemos
esperar tras las enormes protestas que
se han producido en hong kong y las
recientes elecciones presidenciales de
enero de 2020 en taiwán pues atentos
[Música]
de heredero legítimo incordio político
tal y como hemos dicho durante muchos
años el gobierno de taiwán fue para la
mayoría de los países
el representante soberano de la nación
china pero claro la cada vez mayor
influencia de la república popular china
en la región junto al despertar
económico del gigante asiático le dieron
la vuelta a la tortilla
taiwán perdió el reconocimiento de todos
los países salvo unas pocas excepciones
que cada vez son menos y cada vez de
países más pequeños
eeuu su mayor aliado cambio el
reconocimiento hacia la república
popular china detrimento de la república
de china bajo la administración cárter
en el año 79
united states de personajes de galán no
tengo problema con eso
luego la mandataria pueden descansar de
tipo avión área stage realmente otro
comercial a nada una persona lesión
puede brotar agua
actualmente sólo 14 países además del
vaticano reconocen a la república de
china como el estado válido para china
esta situación y el hecho de que incluso
los más férreos aliados de taiwán
dejasen de reconocerlos de iure hizo que
el gobierno isleño abandonase su
aspiración de reconocimiento como
gobierno legítimo de china a principios
de la década de 1990
[Música]
desde entonces y one ha relajado sus
esfuerzos de reconocimiento y ha optado
por una estrategia que cada vez es más
clara y cada vez tienen más apoyos no
ser reconocido como la red pública de
china sino únicamente como taiwán
lo que tiene todo el sentido del mundo
amigos los taiwaneses han comprendido de
una vez por todas que la construcción
política social económica y democrática
que han forjado con el paso de los años
en la isla les ha distanciado por
completo de la china continental
política y socialmente taiwán es
completamente diferente a lo que se vive
en la república popular china bajo la
dictadura del partido comunista son
diferencias que cada vez más la sociedad
taiwanesa y también el gobierno de la
isla entienden ya como insalvables y
contra las que no merece la pena luchar
simple y llanamente taiwán es otro país
la supresión de taiwán por parte de
china de la arena internacional no puede
cambiar el indisputable hecho de la
existencia de taiwán ni puede obligar al
pueblo taiwanés a abandonar su modo de
vida democrático y libre ministerio de
asuntos exteriores de taiwán podemos
decir que aquellos que hace sólo un par
de generaciones fundaron un país de
exiliados en una isla han conseguido
constituir una nación independiente con
rasgos propios
[Música]
y esa es la idea que defiende
precisamente la actual presidente y
premio visual polític 2018 sign in web
del partido democrático progresista de
la que por cierto hablaremos más tarde
aunque eso sí ojo esta no es una visión
única
comitán el otro gran partido de taiwán
defiende una postura muy distinta buscar
un mayor acercamiento y entendimiento
con el régimen chino pero como hemos
dicho kuomintang acaso no suena ese
nombre exacto seguro que muchos os
habéis dado cuenta
[Música]
el kuomintang es el partido fundado por
los líderes republicanos nacionalistas
que lucharon contra la revolución
comunista china que fundaron el taiwán
actual y si lo habéis entendido bien os
estamos diciendo por increíble que os
parezca que el partido que antaño se
enfrentó al régimen chino es ahora el
que aboga por hacerse amigo suyo para
que luego digan que en la política no
hay cambios y esto se mueve más que una
batidora de cuatro palos
[Música]
ahora bien la pregunta que nos podemos
hacer es quién demonios ha propiciado
semejante cambio pues amigos en todo
esto
la pasta juega un papel primordial si si
la pasta y no me refiero a coimas sobres
sobornos o arreglos de todo tipo sino a
la posibilidad de sacar provecho de la
enorme economía que se ha desarrollado
en la china continental
[Música]
y es precisamente aquí donde nos surge
una gran pregunta tú que escogería
luchar por la plena independencia de tu
país aunque supusiera poder perder
relaciones económicas con el gigante
asiático o buscar un entendimiento con
pekín pues amigos no penséis que es una
pregunta menor ni mucho menos esa es la
gran pregunta que se hacen los
taiwaneses y cuya respuesta determina el
resultado electoral
ahora bien hay una cuestión pendiente de
responder que ha ocurrido exactamente
con taiwán a medida que ha ido perdiendo
el reconocimiento internacional acaso se
ha quedado aislado pues no one es toda
una excepción no tiene la consideración
propia de país pero sí tiene un
reconocimiento internacional de facto
sobre su soberanía y autogobierno
sus antiguas embajadas se han convertido
en oficinas económicas y culturales que
actúan como embajadas también de facto
los taiwaneses tienen documentos de
identidad y pasaportes propios
despedidos por su gobierno que son
reconocidos internacionalmente
[Música]
y eso eso es algo que saca de quicio a
pekín pocas cosas molestan tanto en el
gobierno de chiquitín que ver como
taiwán es a todas luces un país
independiente wang debe reunirse y se
reunirá con china la independencia sólo
traerá dificultades y la unificación con
el continente es un requisito inevitable
para el gran rejuvenecimiento del pueblo
chino xi jinping pero no penséis que se
quedan de brazos cruzados no para nada
el gobierno chino el gobierno de xi
jinping lleva años acosando a la isla
con estrategias de desgaste continuo
como seguro que muchos os lo imagináis
[Música]
amigos la billetera china da mucho pero
que mucho de citi no penséis que son
pocos los países que están dispuestos a
pasar de taiwán a cambio de algún puñado
que otro de inversiones habéis escuchado
eso de que el dinero obra milagros pues
exactamente eso es lo que está pasando
ahora bien un momento todo esto no
significa ni mucho menos que taiwán esté
solo en el mundo eso china de momento no
lo ha conseguido lo que también le saca
de quicio a xi jinping
aunque sólo sea reconocido
diplomáticamente por un puñado de
gobiernos los taiwaneses conservan
muchos aliados e intereses comunes con
muchos países especialmente un acuerdo
vigente desde finales de los años 70 con
eeuu por el que la gran potencia
norteamericana asegura que la isla
estará surtida de material militar los
cambios en el terreno diplomático son
sin duda un reto pero taiwán tiene
todavía muchos amigos alrededor del
mundo dispuestos a estar de nuestro lado
y no estamos solos
sainz buen presidente de taiwán así que
tal y como ya os hemos comentado en un
pasado vídeo que os dejo por cierto en
la descripción el gobierno de taiwán ha
optado por la estrategia de la
diferenciación nosotros no tenemos nada
que ver con china somos taiwán y no
pretendemos mandar sobre nadie más que
nosotros mismos ni que nadie mande sobre
nosotros ese es el mensaje de la
presidenta
sainz wen que ha calado hondo entre los
votantes taiwaneses
en las recientes elecciones
presidenciales la victoria de sainz wen
ha sido arrolladora se ha hecho con el
58 por ciento de los votos le ha sacado
casi 20 puntos al comitán de hank wow
vamos que más que una victoria lo que ha
hecho
electoralmente es una apisonadora
tumbar a los candidatos en las faltó y
pasarles por encima
ahora bien porque han votado los
taiwaneses de esta forma a pesar de las
constantes advertencias de pekín
respecto a un nuevo posible gobierno de
taiwán pues atentos
[Música]
taiwán termómetro del expansionismo
chino
amigos amigas de visual político las
recientes elecciones de enero de 2020 en
taiwán han sido una tremenda bofetada
democrática al régimen de pekín
con la lección aprendida ante los
sucesos de los últimos meses en hong
kong los taiwaneses le han visto más que
nunca las orejas al lobo
[Música]
las constantes intromisiones de pekín en
los asuntos con con heces violando el
estatus especial de la ciudad y las
enormes protestas reclamando libertad
han servido a los taiwaneses para perder
la poquísima confianza que les quedaba
en china por eso han votado en contra de
la confianza que él comentan tienen
pequeños
una confianza que ellos dicen se
traduciría en estabilidad económica
'vamos dinerito chino y paz en la región
es decir reducir la influencia de eeuu
sin embargo la opinión del pueblo
taiwanés ha sido muy diferente los casi
20 puntos de diferencia cosechados por
shine when suponen la mayor victoria
electoral desde que hay elecciones
libres en el país
los resultados de estas elecciones
tienen un significado adicional han
demostrado que cuando nuestra soberanía
se ve amenazada el pueblo taiwanés
mostrará aún más nuestra determinación
saint bueno presidenta de taiwán chen
wen ha sabido canalizar perfectamente el
miedo de los taiwaneses a perder sus
libertades por la influencia de china y
ha llegado a ser especialmente
contundente en su discurso de cierre de
campaña fijaos la gente joven de hong
kong ha utilizado sus vidas así como su
sangre y lágrimas para demostrarnos a
nosotros que un país dos sistemas no
puede funcionar mañana dejemos a los
jóvenes de 'the one' demostrarles a
ellos que los valores de la democracia y
la libertad superarán todas las
dificultades sign when presidenta de
taiwán estas dificultades a las que se
refiere este site son ni más ni menos
que el aislamiento político
internacional y la pérdida de
inversiones
el gigante chino está empecinado en
aislar a taipei para ahogar su economía
y obligarles a rendirse a sus exigencias
y quieren mantener a flote su nivel de
vida objetivo para el que no están
dudando en usar su enorme billetera
[Música]
lo hemos visto en última instancia con
dos de los pocos países que todavía
reconocían a taiwán como gobierno
legítimo de china las islas salomón y
kiribati china extiende su influencia en
el pacifico al romper las islas salomón
con taiwán
taiwán pierde otro aliado al cortar
lazos con kiribati si son dos pequeños
territorios perdidos en el pacífico pero
que podrían ser clave para eeuu en la
contención de las aspiraciones
expansionistas chinas aunque ahora la
balanza parece inclinada más que nunca
hacia pekín
[Música]
de los 14 países que todavía reconocen a
taiwán sólo quedan 4 en el área del
pacífico sur y el reconocimiento o no de
taiwán o de estos países representan
implícitamente en el de adhesión eeuu
frente a china
la dejadez de los eeuu en esta parte del
mundo y el gigantesco poder de disuasión
del dinero chino ha hecho que no haga
falta guerras ni barcos militares
amenazantes para asegurarse el control
de unos mares clave para el comercio
mundial
pero no nos desviemos el caso es que
ahora con otros cuatro años de la
independentista hay al frente de taiwán
se espera que las relaciones con pekín
lleguen a ser más frías que tomarse un
helado en pleno ártico y cuando hablamos
de relaciones diplomáticas y china
hablamos habitualmente de bloqueo
económico
[Música]
ese es el reto al que se enfrenta la
presidenta side porque amigos si una
cosa han defendido en pekín por activa y
por pasiva es que nunca tolerarán la
plena independencia de taiwán rechazamos
el modelo de un país dos sistemas
valoramos el estilo de vida de la
democracia y defenderemos nuestra
soberanía
sainz wen presidenta de taiwán pero
llegados a este punto turno para ti si
hubieras en taiwán estarás dispuesto a
anteponer tu libertad a un posible
detrimento de tu nivel de vida tienes
que taiwán podrá prosperar al margen del
'gigante asiático' deja nuestra
respuesta en los comentarios y también
en esta encuesta un saludo y hasta la
próxima
[Música]
[Aplausos]